there is one other movie that we just
finished filming that comes out in May
of 2017 look at that possibly it's a
little movie called guardians with
galaxy vol 2 ladies and gentlemen James
Gunn
Danika
I love you I love you this is our home
this is a petri dish and which guardians
of the galaxy volume 2 is born and I
love you guys so much and especially you
guys all of you you know who you are
stayed out there in the heat and the
lines and not everyone appreciate that
but I swear I appreciate you guys so
much and I am so grateful that you put
up with all that so hopefully we'll have
a couple of cool things tonight to show
you guys right so anyway what's next
Kevin there's supposed to be a whole
other thing that's happening there it is
happening what is it you guys you guys
this oh hi I'm yondu I by which I mean a
piece of feces come on yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I lean on you and I'm a feces
flooded that's what I just said
do not repeat me say something else be
someone else um yeah i'm i'm nirva alone
and I'm a feces just you that is still
the same James
crash let go you creep somebody canopy
boy uh I'm Groot and uh are y'all
excited to see the show
No shut up cousin say something say
something - meaning oh oh uh okay I
didn't go stupid yeah
you all are stupid and waiting in line
for hours for what yeah they waited in
line for hours
god damn it Jeff stop repeating me it is
infuriating I'm sorry it's irritating
you are an irritant listen I'm just
apologize for my actions just two
seconds ago taser faith why can't you
recognize that that's you guys come with
you freak out I'm gonna fish below oh
I'm sorry crimes in action that ain't
got imagination that's and things what
other people ain't already alright yeah
get out of here Jeff Franklin oh boy get
out of here come on go the seats come on
you got actors how they messed up the
air yeah that's exactly what I was
supposed to be doing which is
introducing the cast of lorian's of the
galaxy volume 2
there's a brand new actor you may have
heard of he plays star-lord and his
prick Bret
Oh what are you gonna do damn damn talk
to you not cool
yeah not cool not cool
anyway we also have zoe saldana
Oh
Godzilla Amer in the match by Godzilla
Jeff that's ridiculous okay we have
karen gillan who play nebula i forgot
somebody
Oh
oh my god oh my god - go say Amy Pond
all right okay push it baby stuff
sucking on job you're scared napping you
eat a lift from what you saying
what's even left from me okay next we
have a new addition to the guardians of
the galaxy's we do complement yep as
mantas right wait wait
she doesn't look cream to me hashtag not
my man chest and another introduction
she's a fantastic actress who plays
Aisha and guardians of the galaxy vol -
Elizabeth - Becky oh she doesn't look
green to me either hashtag not my god
damn it Jeff what did I do okay and
finally one more guy we have here for
you tonight he is one of my favorite
people in the entire world ladies and
gentlemen mr.
hi all right you guys like this your
sinuses this is disrespectful it's
understood and I think I think that I'm
gonna have to teach you guys a lesson
and Oh Oh what are you gonna do about it
huh hogun what are you getting here
you're gonna give us another maybe a
sequel to movie 43 on that movie ain't
that cool man I can do it it's over the
in credit listen no it's not me that's
going to do it it's somebody else and I
think I have a little clip from the
movie unfinished then I'm going to show
what you guys deserve Hey
sometimes captain's gotta teach stuff
yeah we need to get Rooker a seat
where's hey hey what where's my chair I
don't get no chair you're supposed to
get a gym I think I'll get the truck
yeah I don't have one here either yep
Jeff throw your chair sure no no I don't
want to send you on your horse over here
I want [ __ ] that's my blouse
there's your chair yogurt now get out of
here I'm not y'all thank you for coming
James Gunn welcome back passive
guardians of the galaxy this I remember
when we were here when you announced
this and it was that was it felt like it
was a different pressure because no one
realized like me were leery familiar
with the with I think a lot of people
learned who the guardians of the gallons
rue this very Hall age it was it was
really it started here was born here we
saw it spread out people were excited
the movie exploded so now that everyone
knows what it is and you're making
another one what's that pressure now
that everyone's like it's better be good
let me tell you it's a much better
pressure when people are excited to go
see your movie instead of waking up at
night thinking you might be making Pluto
Nash and not really what's going on
so I mean it's like it's like people
have been very excited I've been very
you know touched by all in the pants I
just imagined one guy puto - cosplay
wadded up this proton a Johnny Jim I'm
sorry I don't we depend walked out
really maybe that's a really good movie
I didn't said Chris Pratt
how has a star-lord involved between the
two movies have you seen him change um
well he's famous now in the galaxy for
having you know saved so many people and
you know what the guardians of the
galaxy did in the first movie you know
our movie picks up only a couple of
months after that so we're well known
now and he's you know we're really
picking up where we left off and he
feels like he's part of this group or
not just part this group but a leader of
this group and so he's a little bit more
responsible and trying hard to stay out
of trouble but not necessarily doing the
best job yeah Zoe
nope Zoe what was the most fun part
about coming back for this Guardian
sequel oh my god I have to say the four
hours of green makeup every day waking
up at 2:45 in the morning it was a glass
for us
um no seriously I think the best part is
just coming back and working with my
friends working with people that I love
that that you know we knew that we had
something super special because James
gave us the opportunity to just be super
crazy with our characters in the first
installment and coming back so it almost
felt like we were we have just taken
like the summer break and then we were
working together so is it this movie is
going to have twice as more fun
they're super [ __ ] crazy they fight
all the time
and gomorrah's become like this this old
lady that is always like stop it stop it
stop it so it's fun excellent they're
sorry for sorry for the F uck sorry you
know we're all mostly adults and you
know what kids have the internet so
[ __ ] uh
you know what I'll take I'll take the
grenade okay I'll take it
Karen I saw you running your fingers
through your hair which is very funny
because it would real yeah the last time
you're up here and you had the wig and
you pulled it up and threw it I know
yeah it's a kind of weird moment in my
life let's go now I have there which is
really exciting look like a female not a
really long baby and I'm pleased about
that I've never heard anyone say a long
baby before baby thank you for being
honest so how how did you get around
having to shave your head this time you
guys let me keep my hair and I'm so
grateful thank you yeah oh we met in the
middle of London there's like an under
shape which is the grossest word in the
world
I know so little bit a little more
tolerable than having to shave your
entire head yeah that's great
palm sitting next to you what can you is
there anything you can tell us about me
what can you what can you tell us about
about this I'm a new character called
mantis and I'm an alien I have a
empathic powers and I spent my life with
a Kurt Russell's character before
meeting all the Guardians that's it
excellent dave bautista my question for
you is uh we yeah
my question for our Batista's will you
please take your shirt off uh no you
don't have to it's alright
you can if you want um how much uh uh
what can you tell us about where Drax is
that now what can you tell us about
guardian suit he's you know that there's
not much of a time gap between the first
film in this film so he's I think if
anything he's just more confused because
now he's surrounded by people using
metaphors and he's just you know he's
trying to figure it out he kind of
understands what a metaphor is but he
doesn't really but he tries to pretend
like he does so he's just in a lot of
confusion which makes for a lot of good
laughs excellent and then Elizabeth
Aisha is there anything you can tell the
audience about a well I'm sure is the
leader of a species of people we haven't
seen yet the sovereign people and she
enlists the help of the Guardians and
things turn quite sour I'm just gonna
leave it there all right
and then Kurt Russell I'm told you can't
really say much about what you're doing
in this film is that true you know it's
like it's great to come here to
comic-con you guys are blessed but for
me personally this is great because I
have no idea that these girls had a
costume were as fantastically beautiful
is there it's incredible that we were
around this all the time and I think you
know idea um yeah my guy is a I think
James wrote a great character I was
really honored to have the opportunity
to play it it's a great thing when you
get a chance to play characters that
hopefully you will make memorable and if
you can make a few in your lifetime
that's great and I hope that this one is
I had a great time with these guys their
fan dear the best person in the world
why the hell don't you run for president
Kurt Russell you mean amazing I want to
see that betting progress go somewhere
and of course you know like a Ruger you
know I remember after the first movie I
would see you kind of put quarter James
gonna be like moreand oh so do you feel
like you got what you were bullying him
to get I was never bullied not bullying
bullying
I never bullied him as a matter of fact
I think before you even ask the question
I think
yondu in this new version here is is
much more forgiving yeah as you can see
on the screen I'm very forgiving right
and then I never bullied all right you
don't think of to get fully right yes
yeah every time I remember we worked
together before you know that right I I
know I know honey you better fifty you
do not like therapy couch before we
talks about talk with talking time you
lost your hand on that other that's
right uh I just I remember being at a
party and changes houses and Rutger
would just walk by go
you made you make John do cookies and
brought them to a party at night I said
there are these new heck yeah I do
cookie down yeah and he also has a bless
he also kept my cat in hot for a couple
weeks
terrific saying he needed to be in a
certain page count and I was also asking
everyday just finish the cookies did you
with those cookies it was so weird
eating your face in front of you you
made me do that you're like you're like
it's good eat it
you have you guys have another
announcement that's guardians related we
do right - should we announce it what's
an S Guardians the gala I have a lot of
loves everyone on this stage everyone in
that Hall movies and Disney theme parks
is something that I really really love
and the fact that the guardians of the
galaxy directed by James Gunn starring
many of the people on this stage are
finally coming to a major theme park
attraction there was an Imagineer that
I've known up for many many years named
Joe Brody who's here somewhere who's
responsible for this ride and we
couldn't be we could be more excited can
be very cool opening hopefully sometime
next summer not too far away from when
the new movie comes out and also Benicio
del Toro will be returning as the
collector for this ride so we're all
here did you bring anything else you
want to show us I think I you know I
come on man like I look the wrap here
are really cool and Yahoo is amazing as
the newest raptor or newest guardian of
the galaxy but I think people want to
see a little bit more that's the 10 you
got boss
if you say good loud I bet you they're
playing for you
you